13:9 you here two minutes out major
going
section 9 is a group of operatives that
fight cyber terrorism
they're all chosen for that specific
skill set
are mocking the commander of section 9
Takeshi
gives the character the weight that it
needs these kind of the patriarchs of
this highly trained one
but ex-military is cyber enhanced and
not from the degree information you've
got a real understanding of her majors
the one who can connect with I have to
get inside her memory
it was exposing your mind you'd be wide
open how come you're the one point when
major is with bad - it's the most kind
of human she feels he reminds her of the
life that could be possible
okay be full of heart is full walk but
here again he said Rocco killed in
section nine she got it wonderfully
functional inherited family
this kind of just offer I hope the
audience shared the same passion that I
have for this unruly Bunch
breathe do you remember anything about
the attack you're in an accident why
should I sell my body body was damaged
we can save it on your brain survived
who is the major is a good question and
this film is really about the journey of
self-discovery or the character everyone
around me they feel connected to
something
well it did bring so much to it she's
really inhabited the role hidden anger
laugh hidden humanity she really became
the major goddess character has an
ability to adapt herself with any
situation we saved you and now you save
others
this is Major I'm going in this
experience has been like nothing else
I've ever had before
it's a ride for sure
you